hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
we are back by popular demand with
another video
where i'm gonna be reviewing your meals
so i'm really excited about this because
i'm always so inspired by the end of
this
and today's theme is cheap and cheerful
so so important so similar to the
previous videos in this series
i asked you to send me a photo and
description of one or more of your meals
and snacks
to give you my honest thoughts so i'd
like to thank everyone who submitted
their meals for the series
i honestly got hundreds of submissions
and i didn't want to cherry pick them of
course so
i literally opened them at random so if
your meal was not selected
make sure that you submit again and
hopefully it will be selected for an
upcoming video
now of course a big reminder that the
purpose of this series
is not to analyze a specific person's
diet in the context
of their unique needs but of course to
give
all of you some fun ideas on how you can
optimize your meals
and also just some creative new ideas
for some inexpensive
and fun meal planning and snacks i will
also be putting up my general
disclaimers
on the screen for you as per usual so
feel free to just pause this video
if you want to read them or you can
check them out below in the description
to read them in their entirety
finally don't forget to subscribe to
this channel and ring that little bell
so that you
never miss out on a video okie dokie
let's get started with breakfast because
i am hungry
and we're gonna be taking a look at
exhibit a
so here we have two soft scrambled eggs
with some spinach in it uh served with
half of a bagel
topped with some cream cheese and
everything but the bagel seasoning i
know i say
bagel weird please do not judge me
but we also have a smoothie on the side
with some spinach unsweetened vanilla
almond milk
and some frozen blueberries okay so
i'm loving the use of everything bagel
spice here like seriously
i put that on everything if you were to
search
my blog and everything bagel you're
gonna see that there's like
a million recipes there but anyways this
meal is looking
super balanced to me and relies on
really simple staples so we've got some
protein and fat from the eggs
some carbs from the bagel and smoothie
and we even have a little morning veg
love it i would say that we might want
to bump up the healthy fats here a
little bit since
we do have research to suggest that
getting more fat in our breakfast
may help to reduce the risk of metabolic
disease so always a big bonus
so if we want to boost up the healthy
fats one thing i love to do
is to add a little bit of tahini in with
my cream cheese
and then you could top the whole thing
off with some pumpkin seeds or sesame
seeds or
some kind of nut if you want a little
bit of a crunch you could also add some
inexpensive
nut butter or flax to your smoothies
just to add some extra
you know volume some extra creaminess
and some healthy fats
in fact any sprinkle would definitely
work here in a smoothie
so chia hemp hearts or flax but if we
compare them tablespoons to tablespoon
flax does come out at around five cents
per tablespoon compared to chia at about
22 cents and hemp hearts at 26 cents all
still relatively affordable
but definitely something to consider if
you are on a budget and still looking to
get in
those omega-3s fiber and protein i will
also say it's really easy to
make your own everything but the bagel
spice if you don't want to buy from
trader joe's or another kind of pre-made
option
it's literally just sesame seeds poppy
seeds
some salt some dehydrated garlic
and dehydrated onion really really
simple okay let's move on to breakfast
number two
so this viewer made an apple crumble for
breakfast and says that it cheers them
up
during the winter mornings yes i totally
get that i
i always love a good dessert style
brekkie when i'm having a really hard
day this bowl has some apples
rum flavor water and cinnamon with a
vanilla flavored oat crumble
made with coconut flakes on top totally
bonus points for the creativity and love
love me a little rim in the morning um
but we're getting some
fiber rich carbs from the apple and oats
and a little bit of fiber and fat as
well from the coconut flakes i would say
that
yes we're probably getting a little bit
of protein in the oats and some of the
other ingredients
but we could definitely double down on
that by adding in some crushed nuts
some nut butter or some yogurt on top or
mixing some flax in
with the oats to really bump up the
nutrition here
this person also said that they used
water to cook the oats
so we could swap in a protein-rich milk
like soy
cow's milk or pea protein milk instead
but overall
this is definitely a super simple and
inexpensive way to enjoy those fall
apples
that you may have picked in the morning
okay finally let's look at exhibit
c
so this love child between a sweet
omelet and a crepe
is made with eggs coconut flour honey
and a little bit of cream
and then it's topped off with some fruit
a little more honey
and then she said she'll either add some
goat's cheese or yogurt
on top love this sweet take on eggs i am
totally stealing this hack so of course
we've got lots of protein from the eggs
as well as some fat from the cream and
the yogurt topping and a little bit
uh from the coconut flour as well i also
really love using coconut flour in place
of standard all-purpose flour
because a tablespoon of coconut flour
here has a whopping
4 grams of fiber and 2 grams of protein
so while yes it is a little bit more of
a premium item
a little bit definitely goes a really
long way
and it's still way cheaper than other
gluten-free flours like almond flour
if you are on a budget i often find that
buying any of these kind of gluten-free
flours
at the bulk store definitely helps cut
costs even further
now lastly we also have some fiber rich
carbs from the berries
which adds some nutrient dense sweetness
but if berries are getting pricey where
you live
like it is here in canada you can always
opt for frozen
now we're definitely hitting all of
those major macronutrients here but
i also really like how versatile this
meal is so you can easily switch up the
fruit or the toppings
just depending on what you're feeling
like that day or what's available
and inexpensive also i don't know what
kind of oil this was cooked in
but if you wanted to up the healthy fats
a little bit you could maybe
also add in some ground flaxseed into
the batter
or just throw a little sprinkle of hemp
hearts on top or if you want to sweeten
up
naturally without the honey you could
also maybe experiment with
mashing in a ripe banana with the like
omelet situation
just something i thought of because i do
that kind of thing with my son
but overall this is not only really
nutrient dense
but it's super creative really simple
and requires
very few ingredients okay so now that we
are all done with breakfast
let's move on to lunch starting with
exhibit
a
okay so this meal is described as kind
of a veggie pizza
topped with odds and ends that they
found in their fridge and freezer
including some alfredo sauce frozen
spinach
frozen corn fresh grilled zucchini red
onions
some shredded cheese and a drizzle of
garlic chili oil
on top oh my god get in my mouth
so we love pita pizza in my house as
like a great way to just use up any
leftover vegetables or protein or bread
before it goes bad and
i'm also really impressed with the
creativity of this user using
jarred alfredo sauce instead of standard
pizza sauce if that's something that you
don't
have on hand so we've got lots of fiber
rich carbs in the pita and the veggies
we've got some fat in the cheese and
alfredo sauce and maybe a little bit of
protein in the cheese as well
i would probably ideally want to give
this more of a little bit of a protein
boost especially if it is for
lunch so maybe adding some leftover
chicken
or turkey or you could add some
nutritional yeast
some roasted chickpeas or some thought
out frozen edamame on top
you could also add a generous amount of
homemade hummus
kind of mixed in with the alfredo sauce
as the base
which i mean hummus is probably one of
the most cheapest things that you can
make
and it would add some really great
healthy fats protein and extra fiber
now let's move along to look at exhibit
b
okay so here we have some risotto made
from basmati rice
made with onion leek pumpkin and carrots
top of some parmesan cheese sunflower
seeds and sesame seeds
and then served with a little green
salad with chickpeas that isn't pictured
as well as some chopped tomatoes so this
person also mentions that they have
diabetes
which may be why they opted for basmati
rice
rather than the standard arborio rice
for the risotto
so usually risotto will call for a short
to medium grain rice because
that will provide that starch to yield
that
signature creamy texture of a
traditional risotto however basmati rice
is a long grain rice
which while less starchy and therefore
less creamy
will have a less significant impact on
blood sugar levels
now with that said basmati rice is still
considered a medium glycemic
index carb so you may still want to be
sure to add in a source of protein
fat and fiber to really help to mediate
its effects on
blood sugar levels but with this meal we
are getting a good amount of veggies and
fiber from the carrots
leeks and onions along with the tomatoes
and the salad on the side
we are also getting some protein from
the chickpeas
along with some fats and protein from
the seeds and the parmesan cheese that
is found on top
so together this will definitely help to
slow down that rate of
digestion and help keep blood sugar
levels even keeled
so my only suggestion would be to maybe
opt for parboiled rice or
wild rice instead which are even lower
on the glycemic index and higher in
protein
so that we would see an even smaller
impact on blood sugar
all right so finally let's take a look
at exhibit c
so here we have a bean and cheese
burrito with some
roasted broccoli and plain greek yogurt
to dip
on the side now i love how simple and
easy this little lunchy lunch is
you pretty much just have to crack open
a can of beans throw it in a tortilla
with some cheese
and you're good to go i also think that
burritos in general
are another really great vehicle to use
up whatever cheap ingredients
you've got in the fridge so here we've
got protein in the beans
and the yogurt fiber rich carbs in the
tortilla and the vegetables
and of course some fat from the cheese i
also love
that this person is using plain greek
yogurt instead of sour cream for their
dip
i personally find this is such an easy
swap because
not only does it taste virtually the
same in my opinion
it's also higher in protein and calcium
compared to sour cream
while also providing some of those gut
healthy probiotic bacteria
as well i guess if i was to make any
kind of suggestion i would say that even
though
i love that we have some roasted
broccoli on the side for some veg
if you wanted to up the fiber and
antioxidants here really easily and also
add some more flavor we could easily
throw in some red onion
tomato bell pepper avocado shredded
lettuce
whatever veg is cheap wherever you are
or whatever you have handy in your
fridge
all that could go into that burrito we
could also use a whole grain tortilla
instead of
a white flour tortilla and while i am
totally a fan of refried beans i love
them
they are pretty high in sodium they
actually have about 44
of your daily needs per cup so since we
already have a good amount of salt from
the cheese
you could opt for a lower sodium canned
black beans
or pinto beans instead which would be an
even
cheaper choice okay so now that we are
all done lunches
let's take a look at dinners and we're
going to start with exhibit
a
okay so here we have a bootable kind of
thing
made with rice that's been cooked in
coconut milk
with ginger and turmeric some roasted
broccoli
that seems to be a favorite as well as
some spiced roasted chickpeas with some
lemon yogurttini sauce oh my god
that looks so bomb so we are hitting all
the
hunger crushing compounds in this meal
with some carbs from the rice
got protein from the chickpeas healthy
fats from the tahini
and some fiber-rich veg from the
broccoli i also love
how easy it is to just kind of switch up
each of these components
just depending on what you have on hand
or what you're in the mood for
so for example you could easily swap out
the chickpeas for chicken or lentils or
tofu
you could play around with the cooked or
raw veg and even mix up the carbs for
maybe some
couscous or some sweet potato or quinoa
also i love that budget friendly does
not mean
flavor free so cooking your rice with
coconut milk spices and topping it off
with a little bit of tahini
is an amazing cost-effective way to
boost flavor
of a generally really inexpensive staple
i don't have much to add other than
if you wanted to add a little bit of
crunch and some monounsaturated fats
you could add a sprinkle of some sesame
seeds
or inexpensive peanuts on top okay let's
move on to
exhibit b
[Music]
so here we have my bff shakshuka
this is an israeli dish made of eggs
some crushed tomatoes in this case it's
got some red bell pepper
onion paprika cayenne and garlic and
this person added a little bit of feta
cheese on top
for good measure okay for one i cannot
explain
to you how much i love shakshuka it is a
perfect dish for
breakfast lunch or dinner so it's the
best i also have a shikshuka recipe on
my blog which i'll link below
as well as one in the mindful glow
cookbook which i will also
link below but for me it is the ultimate
simple comfort food that relies on
really inexpensive pantry and fridge
staples
so here we're getting some fiber rich
produce from the crushed tomatoes and
bell
pepper we got protein from the eggs and
of course some fat in the cheese
this viewer also said that she enjoyed
this with some bread
to really round this out for dinner but
of course if you don't have any bread
available
you could also serve it with some rice
or quinoa
or some couscous or any grain of choice
i'm also not sure what kind of eggs are
being used here but
i do like to choose omega-3 eggs when i
can which
do offer about five times the omega-3s
of a regular egg
even though they are slightly pricier
than standard eggs that you would find
at the grocery store
this meal is so inexpensive you may be
able to
justify the cost and they're a really
great option to help sneak in some extra
omega-3s for people who
maybe don't eat a lot of fish or who are
vegetarian or vegan
also we could totally up the veg factor
here
by maybe adding in some frozen spinach
or frozen kale which is again
is a really cost-effective way to just
boost up the fiber
and the antioxidants finally let's take
a look at exhibit
c
so for our last dinner meal we have some
whole wheat pasta
topped with chickpeas cooked in a
coconut milk and
curry paste along with some bell peppers
carrots
and onions okay so does anyone else
agree that you can cook virtually
anything
in a little coconut milk and it'll
probably taste really good
like this video right now if you think
that coconut milk
is life but no honestly i do feel like
it is the ultimate inexpensive culinary
hack to
really bring simple ingredients to life
and while a can of coconut milk is
already
pretty inexpensive the powdered version
is even
cheaper so you just kind of add a little
bit of water and you have a more
flavorful
liquid for cooking things like rice or
quinoa
or for making a sauce now with that said
i love
this curry dish as an easy plant-based
meal option
i also really like the idea of using
whole wheat pasta noodles instead of the
standard rice
or kind of asian rice noodles which will
also add some extra fiber
and other micronutrients like manganese
and magnesium
we've also got some extra fiber and
protein from the chickpeas
fat from the coconut milk along some
extra fiber rich veg as well
so my bet is that this is a pretty
satiating
and also really inexpensive meal now if
we wanted to boost up the veg however
you could throw in some frozen spinach
or frozen butternut squash or when
zucchini is in season
and really cheap you could spiralize one
of those in there as well
and i also might suggest squeezing a
little bit of lime juice into the sauce
which would add some extra vitamin c to
help increase the iron absorption from
the chickpeas
that not only will add a lot of flavor
but it's also a particularly important
tip for some my plant-based friends
okay so last but not least let's move on
to snacks
so here we have a snack size yogurt bowl
made with full fat greek yogurt mixed
with a little bit of chia jam
and topped with peanut butter
strawberries granola
and some more chia jam i mean i am
definitely a fan of this snack
for the use of chia jam alone if you've
been a long time subscriber or follower
of mine
you'll know that chia jam is quite
literally my jam
but anyways if you have yet to jump on
the chia jam train
i'm gonna leave a link to my recipe down
in the description box
below it's so good um but i love making
chia jam because you can just use up any
frozen fruit or fresh
fruit that's kind of about to go bad and
it's a lot lower in sugar than
store-bought jellies or jams
plus in one tablespoon of chia seeds
there's a whopping
five grams of fiber and three grams of
protein so
it's a really cost effective way to
boost nutrition
i also love that we're using full fat
greek yogurt which has
an impressive 20 grams of protein per
cup
and also agreed on going with the higher
fat dairy option
since research does suggest that it not
only helps you feel
more satiated due to the extra fat
content but it may also possess
unique benefits for weight management
and blood sugar regulation
but generally speaking i am loving a
good yogurt bowl for a balanced snack
you know we've got protein and fat in
the yogurt and the chia seeds
and some fiber-rich carbs from the
granola and fruit i would say however
because some granolas are really high in
added sugar
if you wanted to have that crunch factor
and up the healthy fats a bit more
you could definitely add in some extra
chia hemp
flax seeds sunflower seeds inexpensive
nuts
whatever you have in your pantry or if
you want to up the fiber content
you could also add in like a little
handful of brand cereal which
is one of my favorite personal crunchy
additions to
any kind of yogurt bowl but yeah this
looks super great
so let's move on to exhibit b
here we have some energy balls made with
peanut butter
rolled oats honey ground flaxseed
and raisins so yum energy balls are
another great example of a snack that
you can make easily
and inexpensively while also allowing
for some versatility depending on what
you have sitting in your pantry
so in this case we're getting healthy
fats and protein from the peanut butter
which
will also help to bind the energy balls
together with the fiber-rich oats i
also love the addition of raisins for
some natural sweetness which
are such an inexpensive pantry staple
and of course we've also got some
healthy fats from the flaxseed as well i
actually often make energy balls with my
son because
you really can't mess them up and
sometimes you know if
he adds too much of the dry ingredients
you could just bring it back with some
more nut butter or sweetener to kind of
like bind things together
also pro mom tip here folks put a few
chocolate chips or like sprinkles in
them
and they become a really hot commodity
we call them cookie balls in my house i
would say that if you want to up the
protein a bit or cut back on the
sugar since energy balls are typically
higher in sugar
hence the name energy balls you could
add some powdered peanut butter
or protein powder or just do a little
bit more
hemp or flaxseed and a little less oats
but yeah i love this snack last but not
least
let's take a look at exhibit c
so here we have banana strips with some
peanut butter some homemade vegan hot
fudge
chia seeds and some chocolate chips
my god okay so this snack is obviously a
little bit more
on the decking side and would totally be
a great
inexpensive dessert option so we're
getting some carbs and natural sweetness
from the banana
healthy fats and protein from the peanut
butter and chia
some extra fiber from the chia seeds and
we're bringing the satisfaction factor
with the chocolate and while in general
of course we are better off getting our
antioxidants from
whole fruits and vegetables if you want
another reason to enjoy dark chocolate
know that one study actually found that
cocoa and dark chocolate
did have more antioxidant activity than
any other fruit tested
even blueberries however it's important
to note that dark chocolate containing
a cocoa percentage of at least 70
percent or higher
will provide the most benefits while
also being relatively lower in sugar
but if you don't particularly like the
bitterness of dark chocolate on its own
i personally don't you could try melting
it down with a little bit of coconut oil
or mixing it into some peanut butter or
some
mashed ripe banana now if i was enjoying
this as a snack and not dessert after
a you know satiating meal i might want
to go for a little bit more protein in
there
so you could make a decadent mousse like
dip
by pureeing some silken tofu with the
chocolate
and the peanut butter i actually have a
recipe on my blog for this kind of like
peanut butter
protein mousse that i'll link to below
but that is a wrap
my friends again i want to thank
everyone who participated and submitted
their
delicious looking meals and snacks for
today's video
i hope that you are all feeling as
inspired as i am to make something
really tasty
out of all of these inexpensive and
accessible ingredients
don't forget to be following me on
instagram abby's kitchen to see the next
call out for submissions
and also a reminder to please be kind
and supportive in the comments
we don't want any food shaming going on
here
but if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with what theme i should be doing
next for these subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen
bye